et s'est invitée ce matin cyril dion
bonjour merci d'être venu aussitôt sur
le plateau de france 24 aujourd'hui en
ce jour notamment de marche mondiale de
la jeunesse pour le climat un sujet on
le sait qu'il vous est particulièrement
cher alors je vais revenir un peu sur
sur vous vous avez 43 ans vous êtes
écrivain réalisateur militant est aussi
poète la cause du climat vous colle à la
peau vous avez notamment en tant que
réalisateur coréalisé avec mélanie
laurent s'en souvient le documentaire
demain un road movie qui a été réalisé
en 2015 couronné de nombreux prix dont
le césar du meilleur film documentaire
et qui a fait plus plus d'un million
d'entrées en salles ce qui est assez
inédit pour un documentaire et puis plus
récemment vous avez aussi et bien
réalisé le film animal qui est sorti en
décembre dernier un film sélectionné à
cannes dans la section cinéma pour le
climat depuis là vous publié ce mois-ci
un recueil de poèmes le deuxième
s'appelle à l'orée du danger c'est aux
éditions actes sud avec toujours le même
fil conducteur l'urgence de la vie
l'urgence de la planète alors tout
d'abord la première question d'où vous
vient cette sensibilité cette voie là
cette cette envie de défendre le climat
si venus de d'un certain nombre de
rencontres dans ma vie et puis d'une
urgence qui s'est imposé enfin c'est
assez compliqué de vivre aujourd'hui
dans ce monde sont sans s'engager pour
cette cause là pour moi la question
écologique est la grande cause du 21e
siècle
c'est donc c'est venu au fur et à mesure
en fait on va dire c'est un sursaut j'ai
fait des rencontres et j'ai notamment
rencontré pierre rabhi en 2006 avec
lequel j'ai créé un mouvement que
c'était le colibri et
à partir de là mon engagement n'a fait
que s'accroître parce que la situation
est devenue aussi de plus en plus
préoccupante alors vous êtes là
aujourd'hui parce que donc vous signez
ce recueil de poèmes on va s'y
intéresser je vais notamment prendre en
gelant l'iran alors excusez moi signe le
ton billet pas forcément je vais essayer
de venir
bien en tout cas à l'orée du danger face
aux hordes de sauvages et aux glaciers
effondré maman retombe souvent plate
comme une assiette maman frêle où se
lisent les plis sur et les veines que la
vie se plaît à gonfler pour une journée
encore alors c'est à ccs les bosses et
ses magnifiques d'un côté on sans lampe
puissance et de l'autre on sent aussi le
bonheur d'être en vie on al impression
qu à linverse d'autrefois le poète
d'aujourd'hui il a du mal c'est
impossible pour lui de contempler de
juste contempler le monde oui j'ai un
ami qui s'appelle david van reybrouck
est un écrivain belge flamand qui dit
souvent ça qu'ils disent est dur de
continuer à écrire des poèmes quand le
toit fuit faut commencer par aller
réparer un peu la fuite et puis après on
peut se rasseoir à sa table et faire de
la littérature là on a ce sentiment là
quand on voit la guerre en ukraine quand
on voit le changement climatique quand
on voit la disparition des espèces
on peut pas être simplement spectateur
donc évidemment quand on est artiste on
est traversé par tout ça et donc ça se
retrouve dans nos créations mais on a
aussi besoin de s'engager et de de
participer à cette lutte qui est encore
une fois pour moi la grande lutte du
21ème siècle alors dans vos poèmes on a
un peu l'impression qu'il ya un refus de
se résigner s'éteint c'est un cri du
coeur c'est c'est toujours ça qui vous
anime ce refus de
de se résigner
encore une fois enfin on va pas rester
les bras ballants on c'est là que la
trajectoire du réchauffement climatique
et de plus en plus préoccupante on est à
1,1 degré de réchauffement les
climatologues commencent à dire que on
va dépasser les 1,5 degré qu'on n'aurait
pas dû dépasser d'ici la fin du siècle
c'était en tout cas ce qui était prévu
dans le cadre des accords de paris entre
2035 et 2040 qu'on va sans doute dépassé
les 2 degrés avant 2050
moi je ne peux pas me résigner à ce que
mes enfants vivent dans un monde qui
deviendrait partiellement inhabitable
donc évidemment on a besoin d'eux
d'essayer de raviver des ressources en
nous qui nous pousse à l'action la
poésie le cinéma
la littérature tous les arts en tout cas
peuvent contribuer à sa veut contribuer
à nous émouvoir et donc à nous mettre en
mouvement et ça fait partie des choses
que j'essaie de faire mais justement
c'est quand même ce registre là de la
poésie sans registre assez intimiste que
peut faire la poésie la lutte pour le
climat c'est lawrence ferlinghetti qui
est l'un des fondateurs de la beat
generation qui ce grand poète qui a créé
la librairie city lights à san francisco
qui dit ne doutez jamais que la poésie
est indispensable même dans les temps
les plus sombres
partout dans le monde même dans les
situations les plus désespérées où les
plus les plus difficiles les poètes ont
continué à écrire on peut penser à rené
char pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
qui rédigeait ses feuillets d'hypnos on
peut penser même à ces poètes qui ont
continué à composer des vers dans les
camps de concentration alors qu'ils
étaient vraiment dans une situation
désespérée pensez à mahmoud darwish qui
est ce grand poète palestinien qui
continuait à écrire sévère alors qu'eux
ils étaient confinés dans un dans un
immeuble à beyrouth arrosé par les
bombes on voit bien que plus plus les
temps deviennent sombre et plus on a
besoin de se raccrocher à une forme de
lumière à notre humanité a continué à
trouver du sens
et la poésie nous permet de faire ça
c'est aussi l'économie des mots vous
avez des poèmes assez court je vais en
citer je vais en citer un coulées de
boue incendie de quel côté la guerre
donc quelqu en lardons tu tâche de ce
monde à reconstruire est-ce qui si
sévères peuvent sonner comme une
injonction à ag as
en tout cas ils doivent sonner comme une
injonction à nous réveiller
ce poème là je l'avais écrit
après avoir été à détroit quand on a
tourné demain qui est cette ville
américaine
quasiment en ruine qui a subi à la fois
les émeutes et à la fois la
désindustrialisation et cette guerre
d'une certaine manière de façon
allégorique comme je l'expliquais dans
l'est dans les poèmes elle se fait sur
plusieurs fronts aujourd'hui on est en
guerre je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'on
le soit aussi rapidement en europe mais
on est aussi d'une certaine manière en
guerre contre la nature on est aussi
dans une certaine manière en guerre
contre contre nous même puisqu'on est en
train de saboter les conditions
d'habitat d'habitabilité de notre
planète donc ce qu'on essaye de faire je
pense qu'une partie des artistes c'est
de réveiller en nous cette sensibilité
qui devrait nous conduire à
réagir c'est baptiste morisod ce
philosophe de la nature formidable qui
dit que la crise écologique mais on
pourrait aussi parler de la crise
sociale c'est une crise de la
sensibilité c'est le fait qu'on n'est
plus capable d'avoir de l'empathie pour
à la fois toutes ces espèces qui
disparaissent pour ces écosystèmes qui
sont tellement indispensable à notre
survie et et que là aussi on détruit
allègrement mais on pourrait parler des
réfugiés donc là on est très touché par
la guerre en ukraine mais il y avait eu
d'autres guerres et d'autres réfugiés
notamment en syrie et on voit bien que
quand c'est trop loin de nous cette
capacité d'empathie dans cette capacité
de de se mettre en mouvement et des dll
est émoussé sa enregistre très intimiste
très personnel est ce que pour vous
enfin pourquoi vous écrivez des vers la
poésie c'est une forme de thérapie c'est
quoi cette fois ci c'est une thérapie
mais
c'est le moyen de trouver une forme d'
équilibre dans ma vie moi j'écris depuis
que j'ai 17 ans et c'est vrai que quand
on est un peu hypersensible il ya plein
de choses
pour lesquelles on a pas d espace dans
la vie de tous les jours pas exprimé
tout un tas de choses donc la poésie est
une manière de le faire est une manière
de oued de construire une respiration
entre cette vie intérieure et notre vie
extérieure
dit on vous êtes aussi un artiste
touche-à-tout donc à un cinéaste
documentariste il y avait dedans on en a
parlé puis là depuis décembre animal
vous mettez en scène notamment des
jeunes adolescents qui font un long
voyage initiatique pour rechercher des
solutions face à l'effondrement de la
biodiversité alors à chaque fois vous
recherchez une prise de conscience vous
proposer des solutions est-ce que selon
vous sa marche en bas je vois que ça
marche sur un certain nombre de gens
après j'ai pas la prétention de croire
qu'un film va changer le monde à lui
tout seul c'est vrai que par exemple
demain pour lequel on a un peu plus de
recul
a donné lieu à des milliers d'actions et
les milliers de témoignages de jeunes
qui ont choisi leur cursus d'études
après avoir vu deux mains de d'étudiants
qui ont choisi leur métier d lui-même
qui ont changé un certain nombre de
choses dans leur politique je pense
notamment à m anne hidalgo qui dit avoir
vraiment été très inspiré par l'exemple
de copenhague qu'elle a vu dans demain
pour toute la politique vélo de paris on
voit bien que ça crée des conversations
aussi et que entre
2000 2015 2016 quand le demain est sorti
et maintenant la question écologique est
devenu central c'est une des
préoccupations majeures des français
donc on voit bien que c'est nécessaire
après évidemment ça ne ça ne peut pas
tout faire alors vous avez signé une
pétition là pour en soutien à cette
marche mondiale de la jeunesse pour le
climat qui se tient aujourd'hui on voit
que vous partagez en fait enfin cette
angoisse de la jeunesse est ce que le
changement passe par cette génération
climat que vous mettez d'ailleurs en
scène dans votre film animal le
changement en tout cas peut être
accélérée par cette génération ils ont
entre
15 et 20 ans ils sont pas aux manettes
de la société c'est pas eux qui vont
faire la différence en revanche ils ont
la possibilité de secouer leurs parents
de secouer les gouvernements et de faire
entendre leur voix on a effectivement
été un certain nombre à co signé cette
tribune pour dire il faut écouter cette
jeunesse c'est pas simplement un cap
risque de manquer l'école le vendredi
pour eux c'est une urgence vitale quand
j'ai passé beaucoup de temps avec eux
dans les grèves pour le climat partir de
2018 ce qui m'a énormément bouleversé
c'était de voir que il avait le
sentiment qu'il n'avait pas de futur
c'est terrible quand on a 16 ans de se
dire que va grandir dans un monde qui
potentiellement va devenir de plus en
plus inhabitable donc on a une
responsabilité cruciale nous les adultes
d'entendre cette angoisse là et de tout
faire pour que il continue à avoir un
avenir mais est ce que tout cela n'est
pas tout même peine perdue lorsque l'on
voit les derniers rapports du giec
notamment le deuxième volet qui est paru
fin février et qui nous dit que les
effets du réchauffement climatique sont
déjà irrémédiable c'est pas peine perdue
parce que
il ya déjà un certain nombre de gens qui
commencent à s'engager dans des
nouvelles voies
mais il est certain que les êtres
humains ont tendance à réagir quand ils
sont au pied du mur c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec la pandémie on a attendu
d'être face à ce virus pour mettre en
oeuvre un certain nombre de choses alors
que ça fait plus de dix ans que des
scientifiques étaient déjà au courant
que un syndrome grippal pouvait
dégénérer donc il ya de très fortes
chances malheureusement que les
gouvernements et les populations dans
leur ensemble
se met vraiment à transformer la société
de façon profonde quand la crise
arrivera certaines extrémités le
problème c'est que la crise climatique
c'est irréversible le virus honda en
sortie on est en train d'en sortir
même une guerre aussi terrible que ça
puisse être sas terminal si on dépasse
les 1,5 ou les deux degrés on reviendra
pas en arrière et donc le monde dans
lequel on sera projeté sera d'une
certaine manière définitif en tout cas
pour les générations qui le connaîtrons
alors juste peut-être une dernière
question vous êtes aussi engagé un
artiste engagé vous avez est à
l'initiative de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat proposé par emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui que penser en fait du
fait que le climat soit quasiment absent
de cette campagne présidentielle
aujourd'hui
c'est tragique encore une fois c'est un
enjeu qui conditionne notre survie sur
cette planète donc c'est assez
incompréhensible que ça fasse pas partie
des sujets majeurs dont on est en train
de battre la ley les cinq ans qui
viennent par exemple vont être
déterminants pour le climat donc on a
absolument besoin de voter pour des
candidats qui sont prêts à prendre le
problème à bras le corps la le réseau
action climat vient de faire une
notation des différents candidats aux
élections présidentielles
emmanuel macron par exemple a que des
feux rouges valérie pécresse aussi on
voit bien que à part jean luc mélenchon
et yannick jadot qui ont vraiment des
programmes à la hauteur de l'enjeu la
plupart des candidats sont encore très
très très loin de prendre la mesure de
ce qui est en train de se passer
merci beaucoup ses rayons merci d'être
venu sur le plateau de france 24 pour
parler donc de votre recueil de poèmes à
l'orée du danger aux éditions actes sud
merci à vous